okay this is morally right to bring
people into existence without their
consent knowing that they will
inevitably endure suffering during their
life visited selfish good question
Tolstoy asked that question in his
confessions so if the original stood in
an answer to that question you know one
of the things I would recommend this
book you read that book because that was
kind of history as we looked at life we
thought yeah he tells this story it's a
Buddhist story about this guy who so
didn't feel then he's being chased by
people who want to kill him and so he
jumps into this hole and he's hanging on
it's like an old well and he's hanging
on for dear life this scratching and
that's the bottom of the hole is a
crocodile and so he's hanging on there
always hey you're gone he notices two
things there's some grapes on the vine
and then there's about two mice ones a
black mouse and ones a white mouse and
they're on either side of the binding
they're chewing through it and so he
knows you know he can get out and Nick
Taylor you can fall and get killed or he
can wait well so what he does is he eats
the grapes you know and it's a Buddhist
or Taoist story cuz the white mouse is
chaos and are ordering the black mouse
is chaos and there's all these things
working at the violent being there's no
doubt about it and you know you're
screwed no matter what you do which is
the moral of that story I told story
look at that story I said look the only
logical conclusion that you can draw
from that is that life is so terrible
that it shouldn't exist and hey dusty st
ask the same question in from his
chromosome you have this turkey named
Ivan was a smart good-looking tough guy
good intellect perceptive and
Cuddy he has this brevity Alyosha who's
Hannah he's a soft guy in some ways he's
not an intellect but
person hawlucha is kind of classically
religious sneeze it's nice to be and
officiated monasterio and I would just
tortures of Tibet because he in blow
over his intellect you know and I can
tell us the story about the gusty s we
took from the newspapers about this
family mother and father they were angry
at their four-year-old daughter and a
long-term health health overnight and oh
she was screaming out there you know it
was news in Moscow an item basically
says Kelly oh sure but you know who's
making a case for the goodness of being
of the goodness of God look at it and it
says how that might be bartered how can
you dare to make money about that it's
like this is the sort of thing that
happens in the work all the time and
then yes Ellie ocean look will you be
willing voluntary to torture that girl
to death to ensure that things would
continue and how he also says well no I
was good hearted says what I know you
wouldn't do it so it's like what's your
conclusion about that being shouldn't
exist and then Bertha asks the same
question he is not Foust his turn that
made that the soft voice and Memphis
offenses he's kind of the intellectual
angle of Satan that's one way of
thinking about it and he says the same
thing he's talking about his motivations
as well what motivates the great
adversary of mankind and Memphis awfully
says it's straightforward being is so
terrible that it should be eradicated
okay fair enough strong argument people
chart it it's not clear to me that
that's where we should go
so because as far as I can tell when
people work for the eradication being
makes everything that they're
complaining about way worse really fast
and so then the other thing you might
ask yourself is do anything cuts the
motivation it's really so pure harder
they're going to destroy mankind to save
and they're making a judgment the
judgment is being is so terrible that it
shouldn't exist now don't get me wrong I
get the rationale for that argue it's
either this rationale has never put more
strongly that in rubbish grounds or it's
a famous passage and rightly so the
question here is with regards to
bringing children into the world well
it's a variation of the same question
you know the question is lucky you have
to conclude if you're not going to do it
here quickly do with being is not with
the being is not just a particle well
that's a hell of a conclusion I would be
very careful before I made it because
there are places it takes you that I'm
not good so and then you might also ask
you so are you so sure that you're
asking that question just because you're
a good person
are you may be asking that question
because you don't want to lose what's
their say of having a child it is bigger
than that
our Navy you're afraid you won't know
how to fortify the child properly so
you're withdrawing in fear fair enough
look what we do with children is he
encouraged them and I mean that
literally it's like you had a little kid
and he say look man you can take on the
world
you don't sugarcoat it it's like it's
not it's all you know fairy tales and
roses it's not they don't like you
shield kids up so you don't damage them
it's a really tight balancing because
you don't want no one overwhelm someone
hurt them while you're teaching them you
have to expose them gradually and with
intelligence and you do that by having a
relationship with kid you don't want to
shield them from existence you want to
show them just what it's like and then
you want to talk them doesn't matter man
you're tough enough you can do it and
you can do it right and it
they can and if you if you fortified it
with that knowledge now they're there
being is not characterized by the kind
of suffering that makes existence
intolerable and so the answer is it not
to have children
the answer is captive properly and if
you encourage them and that's tough
because you know you're kind of
fragmented and broken and if you treat
your child right it might exceed you and
that's annoying
so you may you entertain you cabin
lighting well make sure that your kid is
broken enough so there's no way to do
any better than you and so I wouldn't
recommend that but people do it all the
time
but that doesn't mean that existence
itself is insufficient it just means
that you're not handling it properly and
you're making it far worse than past in
in one of the things I asked myself a
long term of it was first of all I know
there's a distinction between tragedy
need house an important distinction
tragedy is when things happen that
aren't good someone gets counseled you
know your child slips and breaks his or
her leg know your parents die that's
tragic
evil is when something tragic happens
because someone wanted it to have okay
so we can distinguish between those two
the first thing I would say is people
can have a tragedy if you can get tough
enough so you can outride in fact I
think you can get tough enough so that
you even get tougher if you're exposed
to tragedy that sort of Nietzsche's
statement well you know whatever doesn't
kill me makes me stronger obviously it's
a you know it's an overstatement it's
very hard for people to tolerate evil
malevolence
so like I've seen people for example
different have lots of clients with
post-traumatic stress disorder that very
often traumatized by malevolence not
tragedy they fall victim to someone who
wants to hurt and maybe it's even
themself that wants to hurt them and
that's revealed to them no but sometimes
it's that they come into their often
naive people they come into contact with
someone whose purpose is to hurt them
and that shatters them so badly they
can't put themselves back together
evils really devastated I think human
beings to tolerate tragedy and I also
think that if people oriented themselves
towards the improvement of being we
could continually ameliorate tragedy and
I do also believe that being is striving
to perfect itself now that's obviously a
metaphysical statement but I don't
really care if it's a metaphysical
statement I have my reasons for
believing and I think that the purpose
of human life is to participate in that
process and because again the
alternatives things are pointless
and life is suffering it should be
eradicated it's like that leads nowhere
good really leads nowhere good so I can
dispense with it it's bad argue because
the look where it takes you it's like a
bad road map because most profound idea
is a road maps they tell you how to get
from one point without it you know you
want to get to the depths of infernal
chaos or do you want to move towards
something that approximates paradise
well you better make sure you have the
right map and so and most belief systems
are road maps they're not descriptions
of reality in our description to get
there that is what they are so have kids
God say well look it's one third of your
life you won't bloody well regret it if
you don't do it you're not going to be
20 forever or 30 someday you're going to
be 50 or 55 and maybe you'll be alone
that's not so good and so you're a fool
if you don't have kids now I mean I know
people have the reasons and some people
have appropriate reasons and all of that
but it's some ideological hang-up that's
stopping you this tan
you better dispense with that is that
instead of dispensing with the kids